i'm a teacher because i find joy in  seeing children grow opening their eyes  to the world around them and helping  them find their unique place in it i  film my lessons every day so that no  matter who you are or where you live you  can access the world of mathematics and  learn from it and mathematics i love  teaching it's amazing because it's woven  into every part of our lives from the  algorithms that make modern technology  work to the beautiful spiral of seeds in  a sunflower embracing mathematics is a  way to help us appreciate and understand  the world in a deeper and richer way  than any of us could ever imagine  [Music]  you